why yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime it was good to see you
back on the big screen Harlequin birds
of prey proof that you don't need the
Joker to be awesome we love seeing you
team up with Black Canary the Huntress
and Renee Montoya there was just so much
girl power
you and the girls bring a whole new
meaning to chick flick the action was
awesome and so was the story we really
hope you get a sequel of the four of you
taking down bad guys birds of prey as
hit the big screen and fans are loving
it the latest installment of the DC
extended universe has a ton of Easter
eggs keep watching to find out what
symbol you need to keep an eye out on in
future DC movies this video contains
spoilers you've been warned
yeah are we ready Harley Quinn might not
be dating the Joker anymore but his
influence is everywhere one of the
scenes that shows this is toward the end
of the movie Harley and the birds fight
the gangs inside the top of a funhouse
all of the windows in the funhouse have
Joker style graffiti Harley looks for
weapons and flying she had a stash here
this funhouse was obviously one of Joker
and Harley safe houses but it's been
discovered of course those two would
have a safe house inside a funhouse
began the cavity setting that makes more
sense for these two clown inspired
anti-heroes it's not clear who raided
the funhouse though do you know what
that means that means he's not just
after the kid anymore he's after all of
us the next easter egg is actually a
double Harley mentions Robinson Park in
the new movie DC fans will know that it
isn't a new location Robinson Park is a
famous landmark in Gotham City
and it appears often in the comics it's
been mentioned in lots of other DC films
as well most recently Robinson Park was
talked about in the Joker it's basically
a staple of anything involving Gotham
City but did you know that Robinson Park
is named for a Batman artist Jerry
Robinson was one of the classic artists
who worked on the comics every time the
park is mentioned it's a nod to one of
the original creators I know the East
End better than
funny Cassandra Cain is the young girl
that Harley and her birds-of-prey
protecting the movie she has found a
diamond belonging to the black mask
cassandra is pretty good at fighting
already
but it's not clear how much of her comic
backstory is part of the DC EU at least
some things add up though she does
mention that she is a foster child in
the comics her parents are the villains
Lady Shiva and David Kane are these her
biological parents or her foster parents
in the movies we hope we find out more
about them in future films it's a role
here for me another clue about
Cassandra's backstory is that she can't
speak when we first meet her initially
she can't respond to Montoya's question
fans of the comics will recognize this
as a part of her origin story
her parents leggy Shiva and David Kane
raised her to be an assassin in the
comic books
her father's training methods were
beyond brutal he taught her to
prioritize being an assassin over
speaking in Cassandra's first few
appearances in the comics she can't
speak at all
we love this subtle nod to her origin
story also in the comics cassandra
becomes Batgirl for a while we would
love to see this happen in future DC EU
movies Elodie Vasco would be such an
awesome Batgirl okay you might think
this next entry is about Bruce Wayne but
it's not if you think you missed an
appearance by Bruce Wayne don't worry
you didn't hardly wears a necklace that
says Bruce that might seem odd since we
know her one true love was the Joker but
her necklace is the name of her pet
hyena now harley did name her hyena
after bruce wayne but in this film she
doesn't know that Bruce is Batman yet
why does she have a hyena well in Batman
the Animated Series which is where we
first meet Harley Quinn she has two
hyenas their names are bud and Lou named
him Bruce after the monkey Wayne guy
we can all agree that the fight scene in
the evidence room is beyond epic
seriously that was such a perfect action
scene but did you notice the Suicide
Squad Easter Egg in the background it
was very quick but we caught a glimpse
of katana sword the hut doesn't seem
like something that should just be lying
around after all in Suicide Squad we
learned that the sword will trap its
victims souls we love this little nod
back to one of our favorite characters
from the 2016 film we hope the birds get
a chance to team up with katana in the
future we're gonna have to work together
is there anything harley quinn can't do
in the movie we get to see harley quinn
as a skating frenzy in the roller derby
ring it's the perfect sport for Harley
it's typically a woman dominated sport
and it gets pretty violent but if that
seems teams too random to you we're here
to tell you it's an easter egg love it
or hate it the new 52 comics changed a
lot about the DC Universe these comics
are really dark and a lot of them focus
on Harley but in this series Harley is
the queen of roller derby it's pretty
great that the birds of prey creators
give nods to all sorts of DC media birds
of prey is really an antihero movie just
like Suicide Squad Harley was a villain
in the past she's doing the right thing
by protecting Cassandra from the black
mask but you have to admit that their
methods are questionable Renee Montoya
is one of the best new characters in the
DC EU she's played by Rosie Perez and
she's a Gotham City police detective at
the end of the movie she retires to
fight crime on her terms with the birds
but she doesn't have an alias in the
comics Renee Montoya becomes the
question we are seriously hoping that in
future DC EU movies Renee will wear that
mask and become that hero
you're dumb enough to be building a case
against him
you have to really know your DC history
to have caught this next Easter Egg as
Harley prepped for the last battle of
the movie there is a clip from the soap
opera Days of Our Lives
playing on Renee's TV the clip shows
Arleen Sorkin dressed in a Harlequin
costume this scene inspired the creation
of Harley Quinn
in fact Harley's real first name is
Harleen which sounds almost like Arlene
Plus the creators of Batman the Animated
Series got Arleen Sorkin to voice the
deranged character this teen showed the
earliest origins of the character bossy
evolved into somewhat of a hero it was
such a treat for devoted Harley fans are
you loving these Easter eggs keep
watching to find out which symbol keeps
popping up in DC EU movies I can help me
find it seriously sometimes when there
are sequels in a big franchise
continuity is difficult and the DC EU
franchise is connected through very
loose plot lines which is very different
from the MCU strategy but birds of prey
is really great at the continuity with
its previous film Suicide Squad
Harley references and jokes about events
from that movie she is also wearing the
infamous daddy's little monster shirt
and says it has sentimental value
she also cuts off her squad hairstyle
the directors and creative teams worked
really hard at making sure these two
movies had continuity because without
the choker
jurnee smollett bell plays Dinoland who
goes by the alias Black Canary she is
such a cool character and we really hope
she's in future DC EU movies when Dinah
and Rene first met Rene references
Dinah's mom apparently she was the first
black Canary before she passed the
mantle to Dinah button in the comics
Dinah is the first Black Canary she
passes on the role to her daughter
Laurel obviously in birds-of-prey Dinah
isn't old enough to have a daughter who
can take on the title was the movie just
trying to reference what happened in the
comics or are they suggesting that there
will be several generations of Black
Canary who we are beyond death comic
book characters undergo many artistic
changes over time when they get made
into live-action characters they often
get a fresh new take of course fans
often want the characters to look just
like their comic counterparts in the
comics black Canary's costume features
fishnet stockings but that's not very
practical in live-action movies the
costume department did decide to give a
nod to this classic blood at the very
end of the movie black Canary's costume
has changed quite a bit
she has fishnets but they are on her
sleeves instead of her legs it looks
super cool while also staying true to
the characters vibe
she's got rage if you got parts of
birds-of-prey felt familiar you're not
alone the new movie had several
flashbacks to Harley's time in the
Suicide Squad she references things that
happened in the earlier movie but the
filmmakers didn't film these flashbacks
as new footage there is actually quite a
bit of footage from Suicide Squad in the
new film
this helps with continuity we know they
worked hard to make sure the two movies
made sense together we hope that when
the next Suicide Squad movie comes out
they use flashback footage from
birds-of-prey what you are so cool
in the last part of the movie Harley
crashes a truck into a building but this
isn't just any building it's AC e
chemicals and the symbolism runs deep in
DC Canon this is where the Joker becomes
the Joker and in Suicide Squad this is
also where Harleen Quinzel becomes
Harley Quinn it's an important part of
Harley's origin story when she crashes
the truck she is regaining control over
her story it's crucial for her to move
on from that part of her life we hope
she realizes in the future that she is
so much better without the Joker ah [ __ ]
I told this all wrong quick history
lesson there is one Easter egg that
keeps popping up in DC EU films Janus
corporation is mentioned several times
in the movie it's even in the background
on a pill board Janus was a two-faced
God in ancient Rome the black mask is
part of the Zionist family and they're
responsible for the Janus corporation
Roman or the black mask
maybe's fortune selling cosmetics that
scarred whoever used them the mask
symbolism runs deep but Janus references
go all the way back to the Justice
League film it might be nothing more
than a little continuity reference or it
might be a sign of things to come in
future DC EU films which DC Easter eggs
did you pick up on and birds of prey let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to the things see you next
time